how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe today we have some
news about
thor love and thunder and about chris
hemsworth and whether or not he's going
to be sticking around to play
thor after thor love and thunder or if
he'll be leaving the mcu like some
rumors have said he was
but in a recent interview he actually
talked quite a bit about his future with
the mcu
and he talked a little bit about the
script and how excited he is for thor
love and thunder as well
in a recent interview that we're going
to break down and we also do have some
production news for thor love and
thunder as well
so if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
gladiator hulk
funko pop it ends on monday all you
gotta do to enter is subscribe like the
video and leave a comment down below
so like i said chris hemsworth opened up
in an interview
with elle mann and the first thing that
he was asked about
is how he feels about thor love and
thunder and how he feels about shooting
beginning next year
and here's what he had to say after
reading the script i can say that i am
very excited
for sure there will be a lot of love and
a lot of lightning in this production
and he laughs while saying this i'm glad
that after all that happened in avengers
in-game i'm still
part of the marvel universe and we can
continue the story of thor
of course i can't tell you anything
about the plot but to satisfy your
curiosity
i'll say that i had a lot more fun
reading the script
than on thor ragnarok and that proved
something because this movie was
brilliant
so i think everybody in the fandom
pretty much agrees that thor ragnarok
was by far the best thor film
it was hilarious it was really out there
it was action-packed it had a lot of
good characters and a really good story
and right away chris hemsworth is saying
that he likes thor
love and thunder better than thor
ragnarok even though he does say thor
ragnarok
was brilliant which means thor ragnarok
is going to be
even more brilliant but after that the
interviewer brought up the topic of thor
possibly
retiring as a character and passing on
the title and hammer to another
character such as maybe jane foster
thor or simply another actor to play
thor and this is what chris hemsworth
said
are you crazy i'm not going into any
retirement period and he laughed while
saying this
thor is way too young for that he's only
1500 years old it is definitely not a
film
that i say goodbye to this brand at
least i hope so
so there you have it for those of you
who were concerned that thor love and
thunder was going to be chris
hemsworth's
last film as thor that is not the case
there was a debate for a pretty long
time that jane foster was actually going
to go on and take the mantle and we
wouldn't have chris hemsworth in the mcu
anymore or
perhaps beta ray bill could make an
appearance in thor love and thunder and
he could take the place of chris
hemsworth's
thor but that's not the case and the way
he talks it sounds like he would like to
do another team-up film as well
so it sounds like the thor that we're
going to have in the next avengers
is going to be chris hemsworth as thor
now as far as the production of thor
love and thunder ghost it seems like
they're starting a little bit early
natalie portman right now is currently
in australia where they're planning to
shoot thor love and thunder
now of course it is possible that she
could be there for another reason but
marvel studios basically just opened
back up production for the falcon and
the winter soldier has just re-begun
and we know that production on other
projects are going to be starting up
again really soon so perhaps as a
precaution they're starting the
production of thor love and thunder
early
in case it does end up getting delayed
at some point in time
they could already be ahead that way if
the virus makes them shut down for a
little bit
it won't get pushed back because they
prepared and started early
based off of everything that we heard
production for thor love and thunder was
supposed to start at the beginning of
2021 so this would only be moving it
ahead a few months
but the big news chris hemsworth is here
to stay in the mcu
for a while he has no plans on retiring
from the role anytime soon so he is
going to be
our true main thor so let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and let me know how excited
you are to see thor
love and thunder from what chris
hemsworth was saying about it it's going
to be
an epic movie so leave your comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest
mcu news you can follow me on instagram
and twitter i'm giving away funko pops
on there right now and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you